bajo el asedio ruso las tropas del
kremlin quieren a toda Costa hacerse con
esta ciudad del Don vast que se
encuentra en una vía principal que
conduce a las ciudades de eslobians y
kramators según los hombres en el frente
las acciones de las tropas de Moscú
parecen desesperadas
el enemigo intensificó sus actividades
incluyendo la guerra electrónica
probablemente hay un cementerio de
drones tanto de sus drones alcanzados
por nosotros como de los nuestros
a juzgar por su equipo y su aspecto sus
acciones y movimientos simplemente se
están arrastrando corriendo caminando no
tienen personal militar entrenando ni
tácticas
los paramédicos de la línea de batalla
intentan ayudar a los heridos entonces
este trabajo es diferente porque tienes
un período muy pequeño de bajas muy
altas y hay mucho que hacer es muy
rápido y todos los batallones tienen
bajas y tienes que tratar rápidamente y
dura como una semana y se acaba Así que
o ganamos o nos vemos obligados a
retirarnos
informaron de un intenso bombardeo
contra varias aldeas cerca de la ciudad
infligidos en gran parte Según kiev por
mercenarios del grupo Wagner un grupo
paramilitar que estaría financiado por
Moscú Wagner fue fundado en 2014 tras la
anexión rusa de crimea y ha dado apoyo a
los separatistas Pro rusos del Don vast
también habrían participado en la
arremetida rusa en otras partes de
Ucrania según la inteligencia ucraniana
Y britá